I've spent the last decade subjecting myself to pain and humiliation,...
...hopefully for a good cause, which is self-improvement.
And I've done this in three parts. So first I started with the mind.
And I decided to try to get smarter by reading the entire Encyclopedia Britannica from A to Z...
...or, more precisely, from "A-Ak" to "Zywiec." And here's a little image of that.
And this was an amazing year.
It's really a fascinating journey.
It was painful at times, especially for those around me.
My wife started to fine me one dollar for every irrelevant fact I inserted into conversation.
It had its downsides.
But after that, I decided to work on the spirit.
As I mentioned last year, I grew up with no religion at all.
I'm Jewish, but I'm Jewish in the same way the Olive Garden is Italian. Not really.
But I decided to learn about the Bible and my heritage...
...by actually diving in and trying to live it and immerse myself in it.
So I decided to follow all the rules of the Bible.
And from the Ten Commandments to growing my beard,...
...because Leviticus says you cannot shave.
So, this is what I looked like by the end.
Thank you for that reaction.
I look a little like Moses, or Ted Kaczynski.
I got both of them.
So, there was the topiary there.
And there's the sheep.
Now, the final part of the trilogy was I wanted to focus on the body...
...and try to be the healthiest person I could be,...
...the healthiest person alive. So that's what I've been doing the last couple of years.
And I just finished a couple of months ago.
And I have to say, thank God.
Because living so healthily was killing me.
It was so overwhelming, because the amount of things you have to do, it's just mind-boggling.
I was listening to all the experts and talking to sort of a board of medical advisers,...
...and they were telling me all the things I had to do. I had to...
...eat right, exercise, meditate, pet dogs, because that lowers the blood pressure.
I wrote the book on a treadmill, and it took me about a thousand miles to write the book.
I had to put on sunscreen.
This was no small feat, because if you listen to dermatologists,...
...they say that you should have a shot glass full of sunscreen.
And you have to reapply it every two to four hours.
So, I think half of my book advance went into sunscreen.
I was like a glazed doughnut for most of the year.
There was the washing of hands.
I had to do that properly.
And my immunologist told me that...
...I should also wipe down all of the remote controls and iPhones in my house,...
...because those are just orgies of germs.
So, that took a lot of time.
I also tried to be the safest person I could be, because that's a part of health.
I was inspired by the Danish Safety Council.
They started a public campaign that says, "A walking helmet is a good helmet."
So, they believe you should not just wear helmets for biking, but also for walking around.
And you can see there, they're shopping with their helmets.
So yeah, I tried that.
Now it's a little extreme, I admit.
But if you think about this, this is actually, the "Freakonomics" authors wrote about this,...
...that more people die on a per mile basis from drunk walking than from drunk driving.
So, something to think about tonight if you had a couple.